[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute nichts
häufig tun haben und willkommen schön
dass sie dabei sind wie auch norbert
lehmann für den sport mit frauen- und
männerfußball ein schwimmender von mir
in berlin wird gerungen
verhandlungen unter druck seit stunden
berät die koalition über ein weiteres
entlastungspaket die erwartungen sind
hoch
letzte ehrerbietung für einen staatsmann
in moskau nehmen tausende abschied von
michael gorbatschow
und verpatzter start und viele fragen
zum zweiten mal muss die nasa den start
ihrer mond-mission abbrechen
es soll die antwort der bundesregierung
auf die gestiegenen energie und
lebenshaltungskosten werden das dritte
entlastungspaket die regierung selbst
hat dafür die latte im vorfeld hoch
gelegt dieses paket werde wuchtig und
zielgenauer als die bisherigen so das
versprechen in aussicht steht
unterstützung für studierende und 21
millionen rentner in form von
energiepreis pauschalen auch betriebe
können wohl auf zusätzliche hilfen bei
energiekosten hoffen ebenfalls auf der
liste das wohngeld die zahl der
berechtigten soll stark anwachsen und
ein nachfolger für das 9 euro ticket
seit knapp sieben stunden sitzen jetzt
die spitzen von spd grünen und fdp im
kanzleramt zusammen
fragen wir stark und aller banerjee die
das ganze vor ort beobachtet wird es
heute noch was also ganz sicher scheint
dass nicht das ganze hat ja gute drei
stunden später angefangen als geplant
eigentlich hätte es um 9 uhr losgehen
sollen gingen dann aber erst um kurz
nach zwölf los und man kann davon
ausgehen dass das nicht daran lag dass
irgendjemand verschlafen hat oder keine
lust hatte so früh anzufangen sondern
dass das mit der arbeitsweise der
koalition zusammenhängt die sich seit
beginn der regierungszeit immer darauf
verständigt hatte mögliche differenzen
vor solchen großen runden so weit wie es
geht auszuräumen also erst einmal
einzeln zu tragen auf die liste in
diesem fall der entlastungs und
finanzierungsvorschläge zu gucken und zu
schauen wie weit man auf die anderen
zugehen kann und das braucht eben zeit
dass diese zeit scheint man heute auch
gebraucht zu haben jetzt sitzt man eben
zusammen und verhandelt über das letzte
stück des weges zu diesem dritten
entlastungspaket und das letzte stück
des weges ist oft das härteste also wir
haben bisher noch keinen zwischenstand
aus dem kanzleramt bekommen das deutet
darauf hin dass es heute noch sehr lange
dauern kann und auch eine fortsetzung
morgen ist noch nicht ausgeschlossen
dankeschön für den moment nach berlin
chuck unter laterne
aktuell informiert über die ereignisse
in der hauptstadt bleiben sie bei uns
auch im internet auf zdf heute und in
der app finden sie antworten auf die
wichtigsten fragen
heute ist der tag des abschieds von
michael gorbatschow der ehemalige
präsident der sowjetunion war am
dienstag mit 91 jahren gestorben
in deutschland bleibt er als wegbereiter
der deutschen einheit in erinnerung in
russland war gorbatschow von vielen
geächtet dafür den zerfall der udssr
verantwortlich gemacht wird über die
trauerfeier in moskau berichtet für
bekam
kein staatsbegräbnis für den letzten
präsidenten der sowjetunion
stattdessen eine trauerfeier mit
ehrengarde würde voll im haus der
gewerkschaften von moskau der strom an
russinnen und russen die persönlich
abschied von michael gorbatschow nehmen
wollen reisst überstunden nicht ab
ich denke er war ein großartiger mensch
ein großartiger denker und das was jetzt
passiert widerspricht seinem vorhaben
und seinen ideen
meine besten jahre waren während
gorbatschow eröffnete die welt er
schenkte mir die freiheit
ist davon etwas geblieben sind alles
wurde zerstört und wird jetzt endgültig
erledigt
derjenige der dafür verantwortlich ist
nahm sich am sarg von gorbatschow etwa
30 sekunden zeit schon am donnerstag
heute hatte der präsident andere termine
als einziger regierungschef der eu heißt
viktor orban an der westen auch
deutschland schickt seine diplomaten
und die atmosphäre die gorbatschow
geschaffen hat gibt es nicht mehr er
selbst hielt das für seinen größten
misserfolg genauer gesagt sah er seine
hauptleistung darin dass er den kalten
krieg beendete doch jetzt ist der kalte
krieg zurück
gorbatschow bleibt in russland
umstritten doch diejenigen die wie er an
frieden und freiheit glauben wollen
konnten dies heute öffentlich zeigen
eine sehr selten gewordene gelegenheit
dem heutigen russland mit all seinen
repressionen
es fließt kein russisches gas durch die
pipeline nord stream einst nach
deutschland das ist der stand auch heute
abend nach der dreitägigen wartungen
müsse jetzt noch ein öl austritt
gestoppt werden so die begründung von
gazprom ein foto auf telegramm soll ein
leck zeigen eigentlich kein grund den
betrieb einzustellen urteilt die
bundesnetzagentur die lage sei
angespannt die gasversorgung in
deutschland aber stabil auch die
speicher sollen sich weiter füllen der
speicher stand lag heute mittag bei
84,5 prozent
in die ukraine da behauptet russland
ukrainische einheiten hätten das
atomkraftwerk sabrina wieder beschossen
eine wichtige stromleitung sei
unterbrochen worden die experten der
internationalen atomenergiebehörde
hatten sich bereits gestern über den
anhaltenden beschuss besorgt gezeigt
weiter südwestlich verstärken die
ukraine ihre gegenoffensive von nikolov
aus auf die russisch besetzte gegend um
carson von dort berichtet un-gipfel
durch große raketen zerstörte wohnhäuser
im ukrainisch kontrollierten nikolaev
schießen jeden tag immer wieder es kann
überall jederzeit einschlagen
wir verlassen die stadt und fahren in
richtung frontlinie ungefähr zehn
kilometer von hier entfernt versucht die
ukrainische armee die russischen truppen
zurückzudrängen
im dorf saloniki entdecken wie eine
zerstörte schule sie wurde von zwei
raketen getroffen sagt uns bürgermeister
oleg billy pankow
der direktor ist beim angriff ums leben
gekommen
150 kinder haben überlebt im keller
konnten sie sich verstecken
dieses haus wurde bereits am 10 april
getroffen svitlana die ihr lebt will
trotzdem bleiben auch wenn es kein gas
und keinen strom mehr gibt und der
beschuss durch russische truppen weiter
geht
dann nehme ich die kissen und halte mir
die ohren zu mehr kann ich nicht tun
im dorf schewtschenko wer wird eine
kirche zum humanitären stützpunkt
lebensmittel brot und medikamente werden
an bedürftige verteilt die offensive der
ukrainischen armee ganz in der nähe
bewegt die menschen
die ganze ukraine soll befreit werden
wir sind dafür damit wir in ruhe leben
können
wenig später sehen wie ukrainisches
militär das artillerie verlegt
die usa wollen taiwan waffensysteme im
wert von über einer milliarde euro
liefern darunter radaranlagen zur
luftabwehr
eine raketensysteme das weiße haus
begründet das mit zunehmendem druck
chinas auf taiwan das sich als
unabhängig ansieht china reagiert scharf
der schritt der usa gefährde die
stabilität in der region
seit wochen kämpft pakistan mit
verheerenden regenfällen jetzt sind bei
neuen überflutungen mindestens weitere
50 menschen ums leben gekommen damit
erhöht sich die zahl der toten auf fast
millionen menschen haben ihre häuser
verloren
internationale hilfe ist angelaufen doch
der transport von lebensmitteln in den
flutgebieten gestaltet sich sehr
schwierig
in fünf wochen wählt niedersachsen einen
neuen landtag bislang regiert dort
ministerpräsident stephan weil spd mit
einer großen koalition und mit guten
chancen auf eine dritte amtszeit doch
die krise bestimmt den wahlkampf und
weiz vorsprung ist geschmolzen sein
größter konkurrent ist ausgerechnet sein
wirtschaftsminister bernd althusmann von
der cdu fabian köhler berichtet mit dem
cdu-chef gemeinsam wahlkampfauftakt in
osnabrück wirtschaftsminister bernd
althusmann stimmt mit deutlichen worten
die niedersachsen ein selten war ein
landtagswahlkampf so energiegeladen so
bundespolitisch
glaube dieser ampel kein wort und diese
landtagswahl ist am ende auch eine
abstimmung über die zukunft dieser ampel
sie redet viel über entlastung die
größte belastung für deutschland ist
diese ampel der amtierende
ministerpräsident stephan weil unterwegs
in seinem wahlkreis in hannover er will
das dritte mal ministerpräsident werden
aber raus aus der gruppe ganz
staatsmännisch präsentiert er sich wir
haben in der pandemie viele unternehmen
viele selbstständige existenzen gerettet
durch ein entschiedenes staatliches
eingreifen
und es ist notwendig dass in einer
situation wo es jetzt um die sorgen von
vielen menschen geht wiederum der staat
sehr engagiert sehr entschieden auftritt
mit ihr würde die spd gerne koalieren
haustür werbung für die eigene sache die
grünen treten mit einer doppelspitze an
werden auch von der cdu geschmeichelt
hamburg kritisiert die politik der groko
wir haben eine regierung die derzeit
eben gerade nicht in den bestand und
auch nicht in zukunftsfähige
investitionen wie die energiewende die
digitalisierung oder auch investitionen
in den bestand und die mobilitäts wende
tätig und das wollen wir ändern
rauchzeichen bei der fdp die liberalen
um spitzenkandidat stefan birkner wollen
mitregieren dass es eng werden könnte
davon will man hier nichts wissen
wirkner orientiert sich an der ampel sie
hilft weil sie zeigt dass die fdp
verantwortung übernimmt im bund in
schwierigen zeiten auch mit partnern wo
das jetzt nicht unbedingt nahe liegt
zusammenzuarbeiten aber es zeigt eben
dass wir bereit und in der lage sind zu
gestalten auch in unbequemen situation
verantwortung zu übernehmen die afg
möchte das zweite mal in folge in den
landtag einziehen der landesverband gilt
als zerstritten doch das schiebt
spitzenkandidat stefan marcinowski
beiseite sein ziel ein zweistelliges
ergebnis wir wollen punkten mit
ehrlichkeit und der vernunft das heißt
den leuten eine ehrliche alternative zu
einem verbrauchten altparteien zu
liefern ich erfahre zuspruch und ich
kann ihnen sagen diese wahl wird eine
überraschung für die demoskopen geben
wer das rennen macht am 9 oktober wird
in niedersachsen gewählt
alle augen waren heute wieder auf
florida gerichtet zweiter versucht die
nasa am mond mission artemis zu starten
doch der countdown wurde wieder gestoppt
wie bereits am montag traten an der neu
entwickelten rakete technische probleme
auf so musste der zweite versuch in cape
canaveral nach zweieinhalb stunden vor
dem start abgebrochen werden der
geplante testflug soll die unbemannte
orion kapsel zum mond und wieder zurück
susanne freitag ist in cape canaveral
woran lag's susanne warum hat das wieder
nicht geklappt
ja es gab ein problem beim betanken und
offenbar lag dieses problem nicht direkt
an der rakete sondern an der struktur
die zum betanken notwendig ist was es
genau war das werden wir vermutlich in
etwa vier stunden erfahren dann möchte
die nasa eine pressekonferenz geben und
über die genauen ursachen informieren
dann wird sich auch klären ob man dieses
problem lösen kann während die rakete
noch draußen steht dann gäbe es eine
neue möglichkeit für einen startversuch
am montag oder am dienstag wenn das
problem aber größer ist dann müsste die
rakete zurück ins montage gebäude und
dann ist der nächste startversuch erst
in mehreren wochen möglich ist dieses
erneute scheitern peinlich für die nase
so kann man das glaube ich nicht
unbedingt sagen es wenn man experten
befragt die mit dem bau von raketen zu
tun haben oder zu tun hatten auch in
früheren zeiten starts von dieser
größenordnung haben selten beim ersten
mal geklappt und manchmal auch beim
zweiten und dritten nicht das ist eine
hoch komplexe technologie und was für
die nasa wirklich peinlich wäre bei
einem solchen projekt es geht um
zweistellige milliarden-beträge wäre
wenn man jetzt ein risiko eingeht und
die rakete nach oben geschickt und sie
würde auf halber strecke explodieren
oder nicht oben ankommen oder das
komplexe system der raumkapsel gefährden
dann würden kosten entstehen und man
hätte die ursache nicht gefunden deshalb
wird man jetzt auf jeden fall suchen bis
man genau weiß woran es lag und bis man
hundertprozentig sicher ist dass diese
rakete sicher abheben kann vielen dank
für diese einschätzung live aus florida
susanne freitag
beeindruckende bilder kommen von der
anderen seite der usa in arizona hat ein
sandsturm die großstadt chandler
eingehüllt die riesige staubwolke
breitete sich auf mehr als 80 kilometer
aus autofahrer wurden aufgefordert
sofort anzuhalten und den sturm
abzuwarten tausende haushalte waren
zeitweise ohne strom
und jetzt applaus für die fußball
nationalmannschaft der frauen hat
vorzeitig die qualifikation für die em
geschafft genau durch den 13 0 im
vorletzten gruppenspiel in der türkei
nach der deutschen fußball gala bei der
em in england heute ein eher
schweißtreibende arbeitssieg stadt
spielerischen zauber am ende aber ein
hochverdienter sieg
erst ein handspiel der türkischen nummer
9 lässt den knoten für das deutsche team
platzen felizitas rauch verwandelt den
fälligen strafstoß zur befreienden
einzelnen 0 führung nach knapp einer
stunde bundes trainerin voss-tecklenburg
muss danach nur zwei minuten auf den
nächsten treffer warten klara buhl
endlich mal kein abwehr war in der stark
kämpfenden türkinnen im weg dann noch
ein treffer der eingewechselten lehrer
schüler zum 13 0 endstand
wm-qualifikation geschafft
zur fußball bundesliga haben die bayern
erneut unentschieden gespielt diesmal
gegen union und die tabellenführung
abgegeben die bisherigen ergebnisse des
fünften spieltages union berlin gegen
münchen eins zu eins ebenso stuttgart
gegen aufsteiger schalke bochum verliert
gegen den anderen aufsteiger aus berlin
nur zu 2 heimniederlage auch für
wolfsburg 2 2 4 gegen köln und
leverkusen verliert gegen freiburg mit 2
zu 3 das abendspiel frankfurt gegen
leipzig und bereits gestern schlug der
bvb die tsg hoffenheim mit 1 0 ein blick
auf die tabelle der neue spitzenreiter
heißt sc freiburg punktgleich mit
dortmund bayern dritter union vierter
köln rauf auf die fünf vor hoffenheim
und die zweite tabellenhälfte beginnt
mit leipzig wolfsburg sechzehnter härter
vorerst siebzehnter und bochum
tabellenletzter das abendspiel frankfurt
gegen leipzig ausführlich bei uns zu
sehen im aktuellen sportstudio um 23 uhr
zu gast basketball-legende dirk nowitzki
ja und der wird heute nachmittag seinen
spaß gehabt haben bei der basketball-em
deutschlands zweite spiel deutschlands
zweiter sieg nach frankreich nun gegen
bosnien herzegowina
kapitän dennis schröder und der gesamten
mannschaft gelingt eine deutliche
leistungssteigerung nach der pause
deutschland führt im schlussviertel mit
bis zu 15 punkten vorsprung
aber dem nba-star unterlaufen auf
flüchtigkeitsfehler kurz vor schluss
kann bosnien herzegowina so noch einmal
bis auf sechs punkte heran kommen
das zittern wird beendet durch einen
distanzwurf von franz wagner zum 90 zu
80 entstand 92 zu 82 nach dem zweiten
sieg ist das achtelfinale nun nicht mehr
fern
formel 1 weltmeister max verstappen
startet morgen beim großen preis der
niederlande von der pole position im
qualifying konnte er sich knapp gegen
seinen schärfsten konkurrenten charlie
klärt durchsetzen tennis ikone serena
williams ist bei den us open in der
dritten runde ausgeschieden
die 40 jährige us amerikanerin verlor in
einem über dreistündigen packenden duell
gegen die australierin einer tonne noch
tomljanovic mit 1 2 sätzen und wurde
danach minutenlang von den über 20.000
zuschauern frenetisch gefeiert
vielleicht das letzte match für viele
ist ja die beste spielerin der
geschichte
das hat sich noch so ein hintertürchen
aufgelassen vielleicht tritt sie hat
doch noch bei den jugend bei den
australian open an hintertürchen ist
immer gut vielen dank zum schluss haben
wir noch ein geburtstagskind in genf ist
eine schildkröte 25 jahre alt geworden
nichts besonderes
denken sie doch janus ist gern salat mit
zwei hungrigen mäulern mit seinem doppel
kopf ist er das verwöhnte maskottchen
des naturhistorischen museums jeder kopf
habe seine eigene persönlichkeit
berichten die pfleger hauptsache es gibt
keinen streit
das wetter zeigt sich morgen meist
freundlich nur über dem bergland
vereinzelt schauer die details hat
gleich christa augen viertel vor elf
freut sich christian sievers auf sie im
heute journal und wir sind morgen wieder
da alles gute ihnen und einen schönen
sonntagabend
[Musik]
guten abend dieses mächtige tief bei
irland hier kommt immer noch nicht an
diesem hochdruck blog über skandinavien
vorbei das ist wirklich außerordentlich
stabil und liegt dort schon seit über
einer woche das tief muss also bleiben
wo es ist und hat viel zeit aus dem
westen noch einmal warme luft zu uns zu
schaufeln schon heute nacht ist es im
westen milder mit 15 bis 11 grad im
osten kühlt es ab 12 bis 9 grad ab dazu
gibt es letzte gewittrige schauer im
südosten hier dann restwolken in der
feuchten luft auch nebelfelder im norden
ist es öfter klar der anfangs böiger
ostwind lässt etwas nach er ist aber
auch morgen noch im nordosten zu spüren
bringt hier eben die trockene luft und
damit viel sonne einige wolkenfelder
ziehen aber durch daran schließt sich
ein streifen mit von vornherein mehr
wolken an so vom niederrhein bis in den
bayerischen wald da kann es nachmittags
über dem bergland auch mal einzelne
schauer geben im südwesten dagegen
startet der tag sonnig und es bilden
sich dann nur harmlose quellwolken
dazu ist der tag morgen 12 grad milder
noch als heute auch im osten meist 23
bis 26 grad im westen sogar 26 bis 29
grad und am montag steigert sich das am
niederrhein noch mal auf hochsommerliche
31 grad bei dazu passendem sommerwetter
ab dienstag wird an die
regenwahrscheinlichkeit wieder höher
tschüss